[Música]
un río que serpentea en la selva el río
san juan
delimita la frontera entre nicaragua y
costa rica
las embarcaciones presentan una simple
autorización en el puesto de control
nicaragüense luego desembarcan
discretamente a sus pasajeros a
cuentagotas a lo largo de la orilla
costarricense y ahí no se puede hablar
de política porque usted ya sabe cómo es
el que habla de política y es seguido
está duro ahí en mi cara otra situación
política está muy duro la mayoría de
nicaragua se estamos mirando una capa de
plomo cayó sobre nicaragua desde 2018
sin embargo daniel ortega había sabido
seguir siendo popular algo pero todo
cambió cuando las manifestaciones
estudiantiles pacíficas tocaron contra
las balas de la policía porque son
asesinos
asesino porque nos han matado a los
meses de represión generaron más de 300
muertos cientos de prisioneros políticos
el divorcio entre ortega y su pueblo es
un hecho las diferencias crecieron aún
más este verano el pasado 2 de junio
ortega hizo arrestar a cristiana
chamorro
la intención de voto para la elección
presidencial del próximo mes de
noviembre fue la primera de toda una
serie los otros precandidatos de la
oposición fueron enviados a prisión
luego decenas de líderes de movimientos
ciudadanos estudiantes periodistas
quienes se salvaron de la redada estaban
escondidos o en el exilio nos reunimos
con ellos en san josé la capital de
costa rica
kitty monterrey era la última candidata
de la oposición aún en carrera para la
elección presidencial cuando a
principios de agosto se enteró de que el
gobierno le retiró su ciudadanía mi
salida fue altamente irregular yo vi la
notificación en los canales de
televisión y inmediatamente lo que hice
fue resguardar me existía el peligro
obviamente de que pudieran llevarme
detenida tm por los miembros de su
partido quienes se quedaron en nicaragua
y por los 140 prisioneros políticos no
solamente estamos hablando de la
liberación de los presos sino que nadie
los ha visto hay algunos que van a
cumplir 90 días y la cruz roja
internacional no ha logrado entrar nadie
sabe cómo están sus familias no los han
visto nadie
kitty sigue sacudida por su salida
precipitada otros ya van en su segundo
exilio carlos fernando chamorro es un
célebre periodista el hermano de
cristian a la primera candidata detenida
por el régimen a finales de 2018 la sede
de su periódico 'el confidencial' fue
destrozada y ocupada por la policía las
autoridades para ocupando este lugar de
manera ilegal
esta es otra muestra de la dictadura de
daniel ortega
carlos exilio y regreso pero sintió que
el cerco se cerraban cuando estallaron
las protestas en 2018 lo que yo sentí es
que en el momento en que el gobierno
perdió el control de las calles y que la
gente salió masivamente a protestar en
ese momento la prensa se convirtió en el
primer enemigo lo cual se confió más día
tras día el pasado 13 de agosto la
redacción de uno de los principales
diarios del país la prensa padeció la
misma suerte su gerente fue detenido
sabíamos que iba a haber una restricción
del espacio político de la competencia
política nadie se imaginó sin embargo
que una redada masiva
desde su exilio gracias al préstamo de
un estudio carlos fernando sigue
difundiendo sus programas
nosotros continuamos demandando la
devolución de la redacción de
confidencial informa lo mejor que puede
sobre la situación en nicaragua pero sus
fuentes en dicho país ya no se atreven a
hablar
hoy en nicaragua cuando yo salí de
nicaragua y lo que percibo hoy es que
estamos viviendo bajo una situación de
terror otra mujer pagó un precio muy
fuerte por su libertad de expresión se
llama soy la américa la hija adoptiva de
daniel ortega hija de su mujer la
vicepresidenta rosario murillo en 1998
acusó a su padrastro en ese entonces
jefe de la oposición de abuso sexual
durante toda su infancia
la secretaria por favor estoy
procediendo a la acusación penal por los
delitos de abuso deshonesto no cuido
lesiones con agravante de acoso sexual
creo que este juicio implica muchos
riesgos y estoy dispuesto a asumirlo
y qué riesgos los años siguientes fueron
una pesadilla daniel ortega nunca fue
incomodado por la justicia
después de la denuncia- estuve quince
años viviendo en nicaragua y
soportando otros tipos de violencia
control e intimidación
ellos se tradujo también en una ruptura
con su propia madre
me decía que quería pedirle perdón al
pueblo
ah
[Aplausos]
pero fue en 2013 que se impuso el exilio
cuando su novio fue detenido brutalmente
frente a ella destrozada por la tragedia
que vive su país desde 2018 zoila
américa recorre con amargura el origen
de esta espiral hacia la dictadura en
general la manera de hacer política
de la de los de los líderes y la
revolución del 79
tuvo que ver con concentrar poder para
cumplir según ellos las transformaciones
revolucionarias
cuando el nombre de eso lo que están
haciendo es creando un reino de acuerdo
a su a sus necesidades de tener súbditos
en vez de ciudadanos
igual como en mi caso no tener una hija
sino una esclava sexual
soy la américa reconstruyó su vida en
costa rica pero tuvo que cambiar cinco
veces de vivienda debido a las
intimidaciones la frontera entre los dos
países es porosa los partidarios de
ortega pueden atravesarla tan fácilmente
como los que le huyen costa rica le
abrió sus puertas a los exiliados pero
ello no significa que su calvario haya
terminado